please welcome gold medalist Ruth
Furtick group the student academy award
is an incredible honor not only because
it validates the work that went into
this film but also because it recognizes
the strength of my grandmother's words
and the power of her story by committing
that story to paper she ensured that it
would not be forgotten and that my Ann's
short life would not be lost to history
I'm very proud that by committing this
their story to film I now share a part
in preserving the legacy I'd like to
thank the academy that's just fun to say
not only for the award itself but also
for the inspiration and motivation that
comes with it to continue to do good
work I'd also like to thank several
people for their time talent and
dedication on this film Jeanne Stern for
her beautiful animation Erin wrath Aaron
wrath for his visual effects and his
much-needed morale support lodi Knoller
whose narration brought my grandmother's
words to life my parents jaan and Dina
fertig who wore many hats during the
making of this film acting as
translators archival researchers and
camera assistants the rest of my family
in America in Israel and everyone else
who worked on the film including courtly
Courtney hayslett and larga chard my
peers in the MFA film production program
at the University of Texas and finally
the faculty and staff at UT whose wisdom
and technical expertise helped me get
from the kernel of an idea to a finished
film especially Matthew Jacobs Diane
Xander Mason Ellen's bureau Charles
Ramirez Berg Suzanne craft and Louis and
my thesis committee chair Paul Steckler
thank you